[Music]
Avengers
the end is near
[Music]
hey everybody its charlie the end of
your wait for a new avengers trailer is
near so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos of course I'm gonna do a
trailer video tomorrow and there's that
Infinity Gauntlet replica giveaway going
on all you have to do to enter that is
just be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video so the new stuff in this
teaser is just Ironman looking like
after they have this big battle in front
of the sanctum here like they cut the
shots a little differently here and it
looks like he reforms into a literal
iron like his giant jet that his
legs form into as he shoots up super
fast towards Stannis's ship which might
be after Peter has hung on to it like
most of the newer spider-man shots are
of him in the old version of the costume
just clinging on for dear life as he
rips the mask off and the ship goes into
orbit like he's getting ready to die so
Ironman might be chasing after him here
but obviously Doctor Strange is looking
at it up here in the sky with his glyphs
so I'm guessing that Ironman sees what's
going on we don't know quite how Peter
winds up on top of it but it just looks
like it's in low orbit then he gets on
to it then it shoots into outer space in
our man chases after them then you get
this shot later with Doctor Strange Iron
Man and spider-man in the iron spider
armor inside the ship but the other
really cool thing like we get that voice
over the end is near confirmed to be
Thanos now I think the reason why there
was some confusion about that there was
like a clip of that audio in a promo
they released awhile ago and people were
like is that a member of the Black Order
is that Corvus glaive is that what are
the other ones the reason for all that
confusion is probably just because the
quality of the audio was so low so you
couldn't pick Josh Brolin out like he
has a very identifiable voice so
depending on where people find the
teasers like which platform they're on
or how they record them the audio can be
super janky so it can really throw stuff
off we get a montage of shots that we've
seen in the previous trailers which is
more polished CG in the backgrounds like
they keep working on stuff in the
background so there'll be little things
that you might not have noticed in the
earlier versions of the trailer like
there's a longer version of the shot
with Thor rocket and disinterested
adolescent group where you see a planet
in the background just a much wider
version of the shot but then we get a
brand new shot of them crashing Thanos
his ship on Titan before this big battle
here so we've seen a little bit of it in
the previous trailers but this
actually reminds me of a more polished
version of what we saw a comic-con
because like you know we've all seen
that picture of Thanos throwing the moon
at the Avengers using the Infinity
Gauntlet there was a primitive version
of that in the comic-con footage but
obviously it looks way different from
what we'll be watching tomorrow and I am
guessing that that will be in the
trailer tomorrow because even though
they show you new stuff with new
trailers technically it's not new if
they showed it off at comic-con so it's
just a way for them to avoid doing
really spoilery stuff like oh we know we
showed this to everyone
so technically they already kind of know
what's going on but the cool thing about
this is that you just see some of the
ruins of Titan so you see what their
civilization looked like before it was
destroyed so obviously most of you have
probably read a version of Thanos and
his back story in the comics they've
already confirmed that we're gonna see
some younger versions of Thanos that'll
probably allude to what life was like on
Titan before everything was destroyed in
this big Cataclysm I know there's a lot
of hardcore comic book fans that are
upset that they're changing Thanos's
backstory to make him a little more
sympathetic like in the comics he's the
person that destroyed Titan like he came
back to his home planet killed his
family killed all of his people he even
had a whole bunch of children as he
traveled around the galaxy you have to
remember that he's very long-lived so he
had many many children all over the
place went around at the behest of death
and got rid of all of them and then most
of you are probably familiar with
Marvel's infinity storyline because a
lot of it serves as the basis for the
black order during infinity war where he
goes to earth searching for his last
remaining child Thane who isn't an MCU
character like he's not going to be in
any of these movies but also searching
for the infinity gems so I think just
because of the reality of the amount of
time that they have to convey his
backstory they just condensed it a
little bit if we ever get a Marvel
infinity TV series or an animated adult
TV series then they might do more of
like the actual classic comic book
storyline because if we're getting an
adult animation Deadpool series later
this year then I don't think it's too
far off that we get something like that
from the other big Marvel characters who
knows what those other TV shows they're
developing for that Disney streaming
platform are but I think we're still a
long ways off from getting like really
big a-list Avengers in the TV series
they've officially started their press
tour I've already started posting a
couple of the
users and the featurettes and the clips
and stuff that they've been dropping
Wakanda is a super important place
during infinity war because it's the
most defensible location on the planet
so this is a clip of the Black Panther
characters talking about their
characters during infinity war was it
like a big group well yeah it was a
senior shooting where we were just kind
of all standing next to each other and I
just you know from what kinda you know
different world the different worlds
colliding it's yeah I'm the coolness of
them coming to to our world you know
what I mean like you know and this is
something so cool about about the
Avengers coming to Africa I wait to look
up you know you know and it's going to
continue mean it's there are two
different movies that are being filmed
back-to-back here so it's you know it's
a long term process mm-hmm after we hope
to write in yeah yeah what can you tell
us thank I don't know what I could say
you know I mean I think I think you'll
the one thing you get to see in Black
Panther and in this movie that you
didn't get to see in a civil ways it
introduces in an organic way the
technology in the mystery of the country
so that is all part of infinity wars
like using it to to the advantage of the
Avengers and guardians it so I think
that's that's what you'll see so while
we wait for that trailer video just
leave all your bonus video requests in
the comments below
obviously there'll be a bunch of new
footage in the new trailer so a lot of
my bonus videos will be based on the new
stuff that we see but there's a couple
other big things that just happen like
we found that the spider-man 2 is
actually going to be traveling all over
the world they'll be filming in Germany
they'll be filming in Europe it sounds
like a lot of the movie is gonna take
place in Europe but they're also going
to be filming in New York City so
there's a pretty good chance that you
get sort of like a
those credits tag for infinity war
Avengers forced up at the beginning of
spider-man 2 this sort of bounces around
International Spider Man style but it
just sounds like there's a lot of
European based Marvel characters that
will pop up during the film like silver
sable for instance and then Tom Holland
himself in the actress who plays Cherie
Leticia Wright have talked about
crossover between Sheree and spider-man
if spider-man's gonna be bouncing all
over the world during his film then it
makes sense that she would pop up very
briefly even if she's not a huge
character during that film it was a
little bit of new Game of Thrones that's
just dropped in a bunch of other stuff
so I'll just update the video schedule
in that top pin comments so just check
that out but click here for more of
those Avengers previews that have been
dropping and click here for that big
feature on Superman in the Krypton TV
show that's dropping next week thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]